[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this meeting of the international
justice commission is now called to
order
please state your name and call sign for
the record acting commander vivian chase
call sign sojourn
how did you come to join overwatch
my unit of the canadian special forces
teamed up with overwatch during the
omnic crisis
jack morrison and i worked well together
and after the war he reached out
can you give us some examples of duties
you performed
whatever was needed
sometimes i ran point for our agents in
the field
other times i commanded the operation
no matter what their mission was
mine
was to bring every last one of them home
[Music]
sounds like you hoped for the impossible
i know
but they gave me the impossible every
single day
it was the honor of a lifetime to have
served with overwatch
but you can love a thing with your whole
heart
and still know it's time to say goodbye
even the best journeys end
but a new one is right around the corner
you never know where that road is gonna
take you
[Music]
sojourn
engaging
the world could always use more heroes
if only it were that easy
after all
heroes aren't born
they're made
attack with me
not on my watch
i cannot be stopped
[Music]
keep it moving
[Music]
now or never
never tell me the odds
i already know them
[Music]
which one's your favorite
mine's tracer
she's like she's not the cavalry's here
you're one of those heroes aren't you
before me i see the future
human machine
you know there's more out there
don't you
even the best journeys end
but a new one
is right around the corner
[Music]
i am your queen
let's take him to the wasteland
one punch is all i need
[Music]
nice work team
keep it moving i cannot wait to brush
straw
you be crying
boom baby
check me out
[Music]
get in there
[Music]
it takes a team to tango
[Music]
this one
what knife tripod
[Applause]
no wastelander
has ever made it to the reckoning before
[Applause]
but here i am
a free-for-all
with zero rules
and the survivor
gets the throne
not until
today
[Music]
did you really think this would be a
fair fight
[Music]
winston
um
what's on your mind mate
dude
do we have enough people for this
mission
as long as we stick together
we'll be fine
if you're going to show now would be a
good time
attention this is your captain speaking
we are on final approach to paris
that's our cue
you may now or on your electronic
devices weather is mostly cloudy with a
100 chance of
null sector invasion
winston clear is a
but the people down there need help
and right now
we are all they've got
[Music]
[Music]
bonjour officer we're here to help
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
good work mate
[Music]
get the thanks to the ship you got it
what was that
take cover
[Music]
she needs help
we can't stay here
tracer
get everyone out of here
i'll hold the line
but
you set to stick together
don't worry
i'll be right behind you
you'd better be
[Music]
[Music]
genji
[Music]
yes the cavalry's here
[Music]
hello winston uncle
let's get you back in the fight
interlock shield
how are we going to stop this thing
[Music]
your backpack
here
[Music]
this is getting hot
[Music]
got
ready
[Music]
me
victory is ours my friends hi lina
brigator oh my gosh you've grown
oh
everyone this is me hi everyone nice to
meet you
thank you
monsieur
does this mean overwatch is back
yes
yes we are
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another of our
overwatch two play tests featuring the
san francisco shock and the dallas fuel
this was shot in hawaii during the
playoffs of the 2021 season i'm mitch
leslie joined here by matt morello who
prefers the short form of his first name
but not get that wrong and we are in
havana at night time have you heard new
york you understand why but yeah the
this is a havana obviously a map from
overwatch one but uh completely new
lighting new atmosphere here at night
just it makes it look so like it's it's
crazy obviously it looks different you
know in the night time but it just fakes
like kind of the ambience in the mood of
the whole map feel different right
havana when you play it on live
very vibrant all the colors and
everything and with the way the lighting
is around the you know the street lamps
and whatnot it's got such an interesting
distinct look to it here now yeah
and that more sort of gaudy hotel sort
of um you know epic looking building
here the lighting of course much more
distinct uh at night time again many
people probably look at this taking a
while to adjust because you just haven't
really thought about what time of day it
was in havana playing all of those uh
matches in overwatch
here we are san francisco they're going
to play close they've got the main
they've got the symmetras there's a good
old classic spawn camp attempt
yes i will get a chance here with
sparkle on offense uh with a look at the
bastion reworks obviously he's able to
move
while in the sentry form now uh has a
secondary fire that's like a grenade it
can stick the players back off on walls
uh and then also the ultimate the air
strike but blister on the symmetra
very effective no matter if you're
playing overwatch one over watch two
playing close to the spawn door here on
havana and you can see that that
immortality field is very effective even
against bastian now being able to take
his show on the road right what's he
bashing not moving all that fast uh
during that turret mode but being able
to relocate is pretty important here out
of the gates again there'll still be a
bastion for sparkle doha switches over
to the main
is that maywall goes up just kind of
blocks some of the damage coming in from
the bastion
see both teams just kind of posturing
now it's a it's a tank battle you never
thought you would see right i know han
bin on the right aren't going up against
super's ryan is see how aggressive they
have been nice pin there on the fielder
they get right up to the responder
they're making this look easy
it's much easier to guarantee those
close range charges now because you can
sort of make your course correction much
quicker super easily finds that pin now
and has already bought up an earth
chatter so sparkle unsurprisingly he's
gonna have to switch to the pharah but
that amplification matrix means he's in
deep trouble violent able to find the
kill the solo effort here from the
batista and with the matrix it really
becomes like another damage dealer is
this this compositions work wonders for
the shock and then they've also been
able to hold on some of these ultimates
for some changes out uh from the players
on the dallas fuel on the red team is
one of the uh you know best things that
i think we've seen so far is uh really
heard is how awesome the new sounds are
and the pharah rocket launcher just
sounds so sick now
yeah it feels more realistic rattly
almost not in a bad way in a way that
sort of makes sense considering uh just
this transfer of momentum considering
you're literally firing rockets
nice little spawn camp thomas
the shock they're able to bleed like two
minutes plus off the clock they're
playing very close to spawn then we get
glister on the trace a bit of a
signature look for him
well you know it's just uh i think you
said in one of our other casts right it
just adds a little bit more immersion to
it because you play against a far mercy
you know on live and obviously it's very
scary because of the hero combo but now
when you see that you know far mercy in
the sky and i mean maybe he's dealt as
fast as tayo did i know most of the
players don't uh
you hear the rockets just churning now
and it's just it's so much scarier
yeah look i think if you're playing a
dps you want to feel
powerful like you're having an impact
like you know
i guess
you know the impact you're having is
proportional to you know the fact that
you're firing rockets right uh and i
definitely think that that's been
captured in a big way here so this is a
classic one from him the hanzo dragon
strike going to go through the store
here sound barrier going to be used the
super sleeps it off for the time being
the carts on the move and or the shock
are in an odd position here
yes this is i mean they have pushed all
the way up back to the door right past
the cart
i think they've really made a difference
even like you wouldn't play this
position without like the may and the
sim and some other heroes that can be
used in a more stationary sense but
with the 76 right the sight lines are
really nice here for him able to put
down some damage at range and then you
have glycerin being able to finish these
skills off it's possible
all right minefield available for han
been here but only 20 seconds are left
he's able to get to the high ground now
where does he drop down gonna be an
amplification matrix and immortality
feel thrown down by the baptist and okay
i tried to kill sparkles down but violet
the lion's share of healing is missing
now for the shock but glister finds the
finish on fielder now
i mean the fuel running on fumes and
look at this out of nowhere it's an rko
from super huge charge wow i am stunned
as you know a lot of these games have
been
really close between these two teams i
don't know how this one's going to turn
out here you know for the shock but they
have put themselves in a fantastic
position to win here on havana
that is
i mean even by overwatch esports
standards this is uh extr extremely
potent defense yeah there's so much more
of this map to see by night ladies and
gentlemen uh unfortunately this is the
only time you'll get to witness it
because
well the car doesn't need to be moved
through much of the map by the shock to
guarantee their victory so let us now
peruse through this distillery phase of
the map
ready
attackers incoming all right so hard
been on the diva
sparkle widow that would be nice oh my
god i'd love to hear just how
powerful her rifle sounds the widow's
kiss of course maybe we'll see it later
yeah it is
speaking to some of the players uh that
had a chance to go
they loved the widow sounded the sniper
rifle they like you know like how i
mentioned where the far rockets really
kind of put fear into you just hearing
those bullets ring out from across the
map is a frightening sight there's
shock look to be running the bastion
here with a may i know on the offense
and you can see bastion's change in that
primary fire
right so it's like
it's a slower rate of fire but much less
spread look at this you can
yeah it's like single shot spread i
believe no spread yep
feels a little more impactful i think
than sort of just spraying with a less
potency perhaps if you can get an angle
like this right it's a maywall there
almost put up right in front of him but
being able to move obviously still a
little bit slower you know but being
able to move in sentry form you get
those off angles you still do tons of
damage yeah i used to say that playing
bastion was like playing the cello in a
marching band right you have to keep
setting up and moving and setting up
again but now you can do it on wheels
blister though doesn't quite have the
torque to get him out of uh hanbin
herbie though yeah they didn't get the
immortality field down uh you know right
in time is sparkle able to control some
of the high ground
but you see even with the lucio right
with how they're playing this
composition
for the shock it's been difficult for
them to track down some of the members
on the dallas fuel because they're
playing so spread out right it's a
composition that really wants to you
know play on the individual strengths of
heroes and one-on-one matchups
there's no fuel that zenyatta left now
and uh the field might want to be
touching in just a moment moves up emp
damage and of course that initial hack
that's nasty stuff sparkle gonna uh
capitalize here from the high ground and
super cow is behind his shield sparkle
deals with tired there's no way they
come back and do this right
i mean sparkle
been i mean he's not going to bite a
kill right now that's attack fighter
he's half hp 100 hp and there's a sealed
in this way this game that might not
have paid off she'll take super damage
now
move back you more powerful had to be
used as a sound barrier but lister won't
be around to benefit from it the
transcendence looks much easier to see
the area of effect of that ability and
it's enough to force the shock back for
now yeah now we're about to an even
fight right everybody at full strength
what are we getting close to here you're
getting close to the blister pulse bomb
and the super shatter and it looks like
they're going to take a different angle
look this is where diva is really
beneficial right you can have i know
honven played the car but also has the
mobility to get away and you have the
sound barrier available
it's a stick he gets rid of the soldier
76 injects it was very low that is a
game-winning play for the tracer on the
high ground self-destruct there but
there's no way hanbin's going to get
back in the mech it's just doha on his
lonesome and the san francisco shock get
across the line a short-lived stash on
havana and the shock take it away
thanks for joining us for this preview
match from the overwatch 2 play test you
can catch more overwatch 2 action more
from the best pros in the overwatch
league and more from the two of us right
here on the play overwatch youtube
channel stay tuned and we'll see you
then
look up there that's the command ship
this badly
incoming
not if we can do anything about it
echo are you there we're gonna need a
ride
and then back to the beach
meet you there copy that we're on our
way
watch out for the obliterator on the
balcony
pleasure
oh
obliterated destroyed
we need to take out that command ship
before they take the whole city apart
i like the sound of that
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
where to
the beach is just ahead but you should
be careful it's probably crawling with
low sectors
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
heading towards your position
attacking
we should hit that
still in one piece reinhardt
all right everyone we're getting on that
ship
echo
would you rather fly oh probably
stabilizers out hold on
this is not the landing
we need to find the main reactor
any idea
there are concentrated energy ratings
coming from deeper inside the ship and
that's where we're going
after the deal this is little welcoming
party
they destroyed the obliterator
today
it's a planet attack but what is the
ultimate goal
big scary door
nothing to worry about
ah something to worry about
fresh
i will show you the life
[Music]
just coming through the windows
skirmishers
oh
oh
your enthusiasm we have bigger booster
fries
enough for now
may betray
the readings show that we're getting
closer to the floor we should head up
that ramp
much improved
just like you said may that looks like
the reactor up ahead may what would we
do without you
just doing my part
power levels are off the charts this is
the place
okay if we can overload the reactor it
should be enough to take out the entire
ship we'll need to clear them out first
look the reactor core has opened up to
bend the heat we could try this
stabilizing it by hacking the system and
remounting the power
we can't get to it
incoming
incoming
we can do this
ah it for the obligatory
oh no oh
the door is open again we're almost
there
what's that sound
[Music]
now this is my kind of fight
oh
hmm
let's give it all we've got
we did it the court's been stabilizing
and causing a chain reaction through the
ship we need to get back to the hangar
echo we need to get out of here before
the ship
back the way we came let's hustle
we have to jump through the window
i'm here i'm at the hangar
welcome back to another recording of one
of our overwatch two play tests that
occurred in hawaii during the playoffs
mitch leslie here joined by matthew
morello uh your regularly scheduled
commentators and again we have the san
francisco shock playing up against the
dallas field this time on the map of new
york you're the only one outside of my
grandmother who calls me matthew
but
now everyone else will too yeah it's a
it's a it's a you know an
old italian
woman new york thing you know and not
seeing new york created in overwatch too
it looks so good i remember when we did
the pvp live stream and we showed this
one off and now we saw a little bit
about it blizzcon line
i i cannot wait to see you know players
get a chance with this map as i know the
art here just looks tremendous all the
way through they really kind of captured
the essence of new york city and put it
in a a much uh a much more manageable
space
uh yes absolutely yeah of the vibrance
uh still present here and
uh it's really fun just to see a lot of
the easter eggs that have been dropped
in here so keep your eyes peeled for
those now let us uh not forget this is a
hybrid map yes so uh the red team which
will be some of the players uh from the
dallas field actually all players from
the dallas you'll uh they'll be on
offense so they'll have to take the
point the point then we'll unlock a
payload and it'll kind of work a lot
like how you know with escort maps
there's a super he's actually gonna get
dmx really early and that's gonna allow
sparkle to take this high ground here
through the train
yeah this train car forms a bit of an
overpass on this map and sparkles
you're dealing with a stone cold killer
pilot he gets rid of both the enemy
dps's yeah the shock messes around
putting i know violet on dps during the
season they're not gonna have to do that
anymore you know right there on the
batiste right he's got a hanzo into 76
coming through that train and he's able
to just take them out and with the help
of that immortality field is uh hon
on the reinhardt you can see now they're
actually trying to play more for this
train right try and get the hanzo in the
76th up in here to do some damage
so that seems preferable to playing
inside the choke and this is a different
look for super he's actually playing uh
the diva not normally his selection in
overwatch one but he's still making it
look pretty darn good so far the dallas
fuel are being denied
this little train card overpass now
maybe they'll think about walking under
we'll see so far though it's a pretty
brutal choke to get through you can hear
ash's gun right when she shoots from
underneath the bridge just
the sounds just so much uh more real it
feels like more of the image yeah it is
uh super's gonna be in a tough spot here
but now the reason you're playing the
diva on defense is you want to control
this high ground right and with uh
potentially the defense matrix this will
be a bob used by blisters this is going
to buy the shop some more time to
stabilize but you know diva you're able
to control some of this train car and
then also if players get weak you have
the mobility to get up and finish them
off
transitioning between the high and low
ground quickly is pretty important look
at this hard pin goes ahead of the
amplification matrix thrown down by
fielder and eats up some of the oncoming
damage drops down to the low ground he's
done a heck of a lot of work here it'll
be suited but the dallas fuel here
they've moved to the point you can see
that's denoted by that sort of that blue
strip around it and again like any
hybrid map it's three ticks and once
they have them they'll access the
payload dragon strike thrown in i guess
the presumed direction of san francisco
coming out but that's four players gonna
be hit with that emp remember initially
to lose the use of their abilities but
it's the damage amplification for sombra
after the fact it's so deadly players
are gonna find one kill but sparkle
turns around and eliminates him
instantly it looks like some
stabilization here from the show yeah
it's that emp now right it does percent
health damage to players around you know
uh forty percent of the current health
and then also it marks them right so the
summer is able to get more damage down
taiyo
in a in a traditional game right
overwatch one where the hack takes the
abilities offline forever as that's a
nice kill there by tayo to finish off
fielder i know potentially the soldier
76 on but the high ground would have not
been able to use that attack visor to
defend the team but that time he was
still wasn't enough to turn the fight
though
no fjordan still the fuel want to go
forward here sound barrier from objects
is what sets them up but there's gonna
be a bob used defensively by glister
hardness wrecking ball again he still
favors the mobility of that hero and
he's found violet who backs right up
onto a mini health pack and is able to
stay alive now thanks to that plus his
own healing he's hit with a pile driver
gets a harmony or from his teammate and
that forces the immortality field of
violet which is removed and fueled
against him at long range and you see
violet on the batis even to protect
himself pretty well is this gonna be a
backup oh
oh no
i perhaps the shock is so taken in by
the ambience matthew that they just are
not aware of what doha is doing either
way uh look we see it in overwatch
league it's fitting that it occurs here
payload's on the move
yes sir
the back cap not paying attention and uh
doha being sneaky is that's gonna be an
emp as well as uh fd got using the
valkyrie trying to keep everybody alive
not going to be able to do so
sombra's role now is um much different
than it was overwatch one overwatch one
she was really used for a lot of like
scouting and information from the you
know dps perspective right and trying to
set up other teammates to pick up the
kills yeah exactly where you know now
her kit it would not change completely
but just changing up in tune to you know
be more of like an assassin now i mean
she was able to be
yeah getting the extra damage on
targets plus the emp doing percent
health damage which is huge against
teams with tanks in that front line
being affected by it doha that gets out
after
there's a hack on super
and and something you notice just by
kind of watching and observing the game
as far as that's a really nice pulse
bomb there
i believe it actually even does some
damage on ejection uh
the ultimates right we you know in
overwatch one you you play and a lot of
the team fights are just a lot decided
by ultimates right both teams just using
you know two three ultimates in a fight
you always seem to have some up uh right
now with you know how uh you know
overwatch two looks here and the other
the current scene here in this you know
alpha you know it's not a there's more
opportunity to you know make plays
without ultimates but then it also
obviously makes the impact of when you
use that ultimate stronger and more
impactful absolutely i mean gaining less
ultimate charge while firing on tanks
definitely and one last tank people from
doing that
gonna get a re-mech opportunity here and
quickly sparkle had to get out he was at
risk of being hacked and even for a
split second knocking out a recall would
have been the difference between being
alive getting back to your team and
falling five seconds remain in the round
now but the fuel are on the cart so we
will have an overtime
emp connects there it's a nice one from
doha and we hack
to make it so there's no cc from the
brig and the card's getting close to the
checkpoint i mean he is one of the best
zombies we have in the overwatch league
so you fully expect him to be able to
pick up the reworked version of sombra
and really start to you know mastered
early on nice pulse bomb meet there uh
from super
uh let's see if they can finish it off
yeah nice sleep as well so they're gonna
take out sparkles
taiyo here with the hanzo this lasts
next rather part of the map is a little
bit twisting and turning so having a
sonic arrow here just to scout out some
of these movements in advance like that
very helpful now as taiyo can be aware
of exactly where filter was waiting
perfect
for that information look around the
room here you know uh towards this last
stage of the map there are so many
different ways you can attack this right
you see the way that hanbin's taking
right now you know kind of attacking
this high ground there's even more
verticality here in the back it's so
open and i think that's something that
they've talked about you know going into
overwatch too right it's like you know
more opportunity to flank more
opportunity to make plays the maps kind
of aid to that as well
so the rally uh the rally quote unquote
armadillo is actually green health as
was the adaptive shield of han bin when
he dropped in there on the wrecking ball
so
you know all of those sort of decaying
extra health effects have been sort of
you know united under sort of just being
green health uh in this case sound
barrier obviously in much the same day
here's the transcendence coming out from
fielder and there's an emp so bam large
amount of early percent damage done
means violet is extremely squishy and
sparkle could play from a relatively
safe distance here now as we're going to
be into yet another overtime with the
dallas fuel still looking pretty
comfortable forcing the defenders back
into their spawn behind sparkle the tip
of the spear yeah the the summer
obviously can put down extra damage but
the hack also allows sparkle to see
players through the walls for a period
of time right so he's able to track
really nicely on the 76 they're going to
have the nano boost super to get to the
payload just to stop it from going in
and look
i mean the fuel respect is for the most
part but the minefield has dropped down
now and super is going to be suited as a
result and well the tactical fishing
hits that much harder when there is no
mitigation in the form of defense matrix
sparkle just deals depth in the back
line now and that dragon strike might
dissuade the fuel to a degree but harm
is so durable he rolls straight on
through of it those last few mines
disappear
but the dallas fuel finished the map
well so they don't have any time
remaining right so we'll see that when
these shocks go on their offense what
they decide to do maybe they play for
that high ground just like dallas did
but the goal line here for the shock is
to complete the map and get us into
overtime and that's what they would need
to do to extend this game
a couple different looks there of course
in terms of our compositions right we
started off with sort of the more dive
centric setup as both teams were playing
the diva trying to control the train
cart overpass
switched it up a little bit there of
course is uh we're gonna see some
different tanks the hanzo came out the
sombra was there as well
uh again definitely a feeling of
i don't know greater lethality from your
dps here that might just be you know
because there's one less tank to look at
they sound nastier and they definitely
hit high i mean also more lethality from
the supports right you know the game
kind of kicked off with violet being
able to pick up both damage dealers uh
and he'll from the talus fuel while
inside of the train car while he's
playing the batiste so the batiste
typically know even in i know overwatch
one a more often some minded support but
still being able to kind of do damage
and i think you know be a force
offensively from every position i think
is really important
so again as you can see up there
the map finished three checkpoints for
the dallas fuel san francisco again uh
if you got to see our dorado play test
you might have seen some high drinks at
the start of the round
we might have those once more here is
the shocker out of the gates here again
they have a symmetra but
it's this is probably uncharted
territory for them so knowing how to get
value out of this symmetra is probably
uh not all that clear of them off the
off the right two very different concept
uh where the shock they're trying to set
up these sim turrets and play around
this reinhardt in the torbjorn uh does
not look to be working out here is doha
on the echo able to get to the high
crown they get very difficult for the
shark to get anything going
uncharted territory for some but doha
looks extremely at home on the echo as
usual
i mean dallas one of the teams that you
know rotated both their dps players
through playing echo at times so still
have the reinhardt from okay super
switching to the road hog here
they were able to make a play right
through the initial choke and trying uh
they made a tp player right but they got
burnt down by that echo yeah but uh you
know they were able to get position
inside of the store to the left and
maybe if they're able to live there a
little bit longer they'll get healed up
they would have been about to make a
play nice hook there from super it's
really roadhog's strength is to be able
to get these early picks
soon super in the 20 20 grand finals run
got some notoriety on that roadhog as he
was
in vogue at the time very fitting to see
him on it here
piledriver attempted that knocked up fd
god but again it's doha with that
focusing beam from the skies that's been
a little bit of an issue from the ground
though this is able to burn jackson down
so no resurrects available and doha
chooses to copy fatigue he respects
violence damage potential and wants some
of that for himself
by a little challenge anybody right he
hears the matrix goes down he drops his
own it's not going to work out for him
look at this they have not been able to
deal with fielder up on the high ground
that's going to be asleep there on the
super and he's going to opportunity big
biotic grenade
okay here's the touch though is no
choice but to drop onto the point taiyo
very low builder's going to be able to
finish them all but
in deep trouble he can't take a breather
in time
and yeah the reinforcements came at just
the right time but field was out of
remember it's a nutty place i mean he's
able to stay up there kind of heal his
team as they're defending it prevents
the shock from actually taking the point
right very close 96
uh gets a sleep onto the tank drops down
biotic grenade he's able to pick up a
kill i mean that is a that is a huge
game-changing play from yurana there on
the high ground
christopher tries to go for a bit of a
back cap at least trying to draw some
attention that pulse bomb goes awry
now super again he knows he doesn't give
a lot of old percent but he can still
get eliminated he's able to do that
though to doha and now he's looking for
the mercy this is uh a one-man army
right now
it straight on to the point bob used
defensively but he'll be picked up awful
quick too and even though that big
biotic came through from fielder again
they were able to just you know stay
inside of the train car
get cover wait for it to wear off and
that's when super is able to go out and
use his pick potential to open things up
and he's able to get to straight away
glister is taking some damage i know
from from another player in the distance
and you're able to get those three kills
and unlock the payload
again quite the uh
quite the vibrant payload now look at
some of the high ground they can play
from on offense right away right
yeah look at that quickly they want to
establish that especially for the
soldier 76 here super doesn't really
have much need for it he wants to try
and go forward here
but all of the in the fuel are really
trying to hold very close together and
get value out of ash here tayo wants a
good varnish point to make this tackle
visor work but he's being harassed by
the wrecking ball he'll go for it now
yes the attack visor here is the shot
they want to push this payload note just
like in overwatch no a lot of the maps
have these difficult chokes at times to
get through this looks like it's going
to be one on new york trying to get
through this underpass so they invest
some ultimates they get through the
underpass with the cart and now what do
they do though they don't really have
much outside of this pulse bomb and the
ant matrix they got to get good use of
these ultimates
and remember that the payload is very
close to the checkpoint right it's just
you know a a right turn at albuquerque
and they're there okay wow
that's ridiculous three players hit by
the pole driver and into the minefield
immediately hanbin's gonna be beaming
after that one but so is doha still
controlling that higher ground on the
echo and super
i don't know if he's trying to you know
do a banksy impression here or try and
save the round he's got a minute and 10
seconds
he's on the flying
he's almost sneaked
i mean which one killed him that's a
pretty good target
hey when you get rid of the body grenade
source you don't find any more than that
though the car does push up a little bit
look at this finds the killer look at
the position it forces them into you
know dallas fuel now underneath in the
underpass they have to use a duplicate
they're not going to get anything for up
a man doha with some help with sparkle
finish off taiyo pretty quick
his duplicate was so short lived he's
immediately knocked out of that
so it barely has any time to respond
violet in midair is able to avoid the
focusing beam and handman works him down
that cartel is still not moving a fire
truck
still looms closely to this checkpoint
we're under 30 seconds left the shock
have to uh dig a little deeper and uh
dallas has this rally they've done a
great job of kind of conserving their
ultimates and playing around them
israeli getting good use of them
and that green health being doled out to
anybody in the vicinity here and empty
god can't quite escape there's a very
angry brigitte it's a par driver on the
higher ground for super and it allows
fighter to secure the kill on sparkle
but there's still four players up here
for the dallas fuel and they're not
batching from the cart great whip shop
there to knock the wrecking ball back
but super still able to trigger overtime
yeah it doesn't look good though for the
shock as dallas really you know
dominating here on the defensive side of
things and oh fd god he'll jump on it
get a touch it just looked like it when
it was about to be over
there it is overtime getting real close
here tough to touch the car with the
brigand violet won't be able to drop
down our first competitive play test of
new york goes to the dallas fuel
convincing win keep an eye on for the
rest of our overwatch 2.
we recently played the overwatch 2
closed alpha and today we're going to
talk about whether or not it feels like
the fully fledged sequel that blizzard
hopes it does or whether or not it feels
just kind of like overwatch 1.5 i'm lucy
james and i am joined today by tomorrow
hussein hello
and our very special guest styloso hello
hello hello
for people who don't know you start live
sir yes okay well if you google stylose
you'll probably see about 4 000 or maybe
even 5 000 videos in overwatch i have
made a lot of content on overwatch over
the years
that's me
one of the kings party praise high
praise
no pressure um for the three of us we
were recently in the closed overwatch 2
alpha which is basically we got to play
it for it was open for a good couple
weeks uh we all got a bunch of time in
it it was all the pvp none of the pve
stuff um so the new maps the new mode
the new hero was all there
and uh
it was an interesting interesting time
um
let's start with kind of
very very broad and we'll we'll talk
about everything kind of individually in
a sec but like what are your broad
impressions stylized so the game is
faster um there's a lot more onus on
individual performance now than than the
was in 6v6 um
it kind of plays in
it feels weird to begin with because
it's almost like a tank is disconnected
from each team and you're like what's
going on here like why have i only got a
ball as my tank or a roadhog it feels
really strange um but yeah it's faster
as i said there's more onus on skill
even if you look at sojourn the the new
hero um
her ultimate when she overclocks a
railgun
you have to land those shots if you
don't then you suffer and it's always
been like a
a niggly pointless with the overwatch
community the balance between like
heroes that have almost got like
uh how can i say this diplomatically
like i win buttons or that they're maybe
lower skill level compared to heroes
that require a lot more mechanical skill
so yeah it's faster that's that's the
biggest takeaway from this is definitely
faster and it
still feels like overwatch kind of
you've just got one less tank
yeah and i mean to that point about um
being more skill-based it also kind of
to me it felt like there was more
pressure on role selection because
you feel more pressured to be useful
and i'm really interested to see when
this goes live and it goes wide to see
if there are gonna still be those people
who are like well screw you guys i'm
gonna pick a hero that's gonna be
completely
unhelpful but i'm gonna go and just get
you know try and get as many kills as
possible um tam what were your
impressions
yeah i i very very similar i feel like
it felt very familiar and
the other part of it was um like celeste
said it feels a lot more skill based and
i don't know it it kind of felt like
there was a lot more pressure because of
it which i i think is going to be
interesting because
the i think overwatch 2 success came
from being able to appeal to a lot of
people and being able to find a groove
for you regardless of your skill level
like you could play a mercy or you could
play a another character that you know
for again using the similar terminology
has an i win bar
[Music]
which one's your favorite
mine's tracer
she's like she's not the cavalry's here
you're one of those heroes aren't you
before me i see the future
don't you
even the best journeys end
but a new one
is right around the corner
[Music]
i am your queen
let's take him to the wasteland
one punch is all i need
[Music]
nice work team
[Music]
boom baby
check me out
[Music]
get in there
it takes a team to tango
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i am zoie schwindt and
earlier this week the community was
treated to some massive news regarding
overwatch 2. of course the biggest
announcement by far was the news that
overwatch 2 will arrive on october the
4th as an always-on always evolving live
service game that will be free to play
for everyone now if you're like me
you're eager to learn more and that is
why i'm here today at the blizzard
campus to better understand the
decisions behind the announcements find
out what they mean for the players and
with some luck uncover a few new game
details for you at home and be sure to
stay tuned for the world premiere of the
new cinematic the wastelander which was
teased just a few days ago so with that
let's get into it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
joining me are overwatch game director
aaron keller and production director
paul hale first how are you two doing
i'm doing great excited
yes me too so excited to be talking
about this and i'm so excited to have
you both here now uh there was a ton of
news which dropped over the weekend and
the community has been
buzzing and i'm excited to be able to
sit down with you too now to unpack all
of this for everyone watching at home
now the biggest announcement had to be
the news that oh 2 is releasing on
october 4th as a free to play live
service that's incredible and that must
be very very exciting for you and your
team
yeah overwatch too it's been a labor of
love for our our team we're all
dedicated to creating a game that our
community will enjoy for years to come
we also want players to feel like there
was always something new for them to
play or experience in the game these
goals really led us down the path of
developing overwatch 2 as an always-on
living game
one that continues to evolve and expand
through seasonal content drops and keeps
the game as fresh and fun to play
long after it turns on we're lucky to
have such a passionate and creative set
of players and
we know that they've been craving more
ways to play the game they love so much
in recent years we haven't done a good
enough job at delivering that for our
fans and we feel their frustration we
took a hard look at our strategy for
overwatch 2 to make sure that we could
deliver new heroes new maps
modes and more to the community on a
frequent and consistent basis
as an overwatch fan of course that's
music to my ears we know that's the
community's top priority and we feel
like we have the right approach to be
able to deliver that for them
well into the future how are you and the
team planning to deliver on that promise
well the very first step is getting the
game into everyone's hands and that's
going to happen on october 4th when we
transition over watch one and invite
every pc and console player to drop in
and experience overwatch 2's reimagined
pvp experience and that's just the
beginning our plan is to deliver a
steady drum beat of new content every
nine weeks through free seasonal updates
ensuring that there's always something
new to play chase unlock in overwatch
too well that all sounds amazing it's so
much of it too and now i'm sure everyone
at home wants to hear more details of
course i'd be happy to share a look at
the road ahead
our journey is going to begin on october
4th when overwatch 2 releases free to
play this includes three new heroes six
new maps a brand new mode and more the
new heroes include sojourn
junker queen
and a brand new support hero that we'll
reveal in the months ahead
our new maps will take players across
the globe to iconic locations
our new pvp mode called push will
challenge teams in new and exciting ways
players will also be able to unlock new
cosmetic items through the in-game store
and battle pass
as well as complete weekly challenges
and experience the start of competitive
play 2.0 and of course everyone will
also be able to access revamped heroes
pvp maps and fan favorite game modes
from the first overwatch game
our next season will arrive in early
december where we will introduce a new
tank hero along with a new map
we'll have more themed cosmetic items
for players to earn and unlock in an all
new battle pass and also in the in-game
store and in 2023 we'll continue to
release a new season every nine weeks
with either a new hero new map or new
mode players will get the chance to earn
more themed content complete weekly
challenges
access new battle passes and more there
will always be something new to play
in 2023 we'll also begin releasing our
new pve experiences which we're really
excited about we're really looking
forward to being able to share more with
the community as we get closer to
releasing them i know we've seen more
and more games shift towards that free
to play model in recent years and it
really does seem like players have taken
a liking to it especially shooter fans
um did that have an impact on deciding
to make overwatch 2 uh go free to play
honestly not really for us free-to-play
games offer a lot of advantages from the
very start overwatch was designed to be
a social experience we have heroes of
different roles and they all rely on
each other in in order to accomplish
their objectives in the game so it
requires a lot of teamwork we also see
that outside of our game within our
community with fan art cosplay and the
overwatch league we know our fans are
having the most fun when they're playing
with their friends or meeting new ones
and the move to free to play
makes it easy for everyone to just drop
in play the game join the community
whether they own overwatch one or not
and with overwatch 2 crossplay enabled
people can play together no matter what
platform they prefer to play on it's
always been a game that stood for
inclusivity and community when they see
the roster of heroes
we want them to feel like there's
someone there that they can feel
connected to because the overwatch
universe is and always will be a place
for everyone and we feel like we have an
incredible opportunity with overwatch 2
to really embrace it i can't wait for
october when this incredible journey
will begin for all of us now that we
have a better understanding of what's to
come i'd love to dive a little deeper uh
starting with oh two's new approach to
pvp can you maybe elaborate and explain
a little more sure
pvp has always been at the heart of the
overwatch experience and we've made some
tweaks to it over the years but
overwatch 2 really gave us the
opportunity to put the mode under a
microscope and we really wanted players
to feel that they had more impact in a
match and we've made significant
fundamental changes that we just
couldn't do in the current live game
this was a foundational shift that
changed everything heroes maps and more
so
we had to reevaluate every aspect of pvp
to ensure we got it right we've been
encouraged by player feedback from the
first beta and we will continue to make
updates and improvements in the game
well earlier today i had a chance to sit
down with a few additional members of
the ooh team and hear more about all the
work they're doing to redefine pvp in
overwatch too so let's take a look
one of the things that
gets us up in the morning happy to work
on overwatch it's first and foremost a
really special game the way we portray a
bright future everyone on the team is
really proud of
it we're bringing an all-new pvp
experience we're transforming from a 6v6
to a 5e5 changed a lot of how we design
heroes and actually how we balance them
as well we had to go back and look at
all the heroes and all the tanks
especially and make sure that everyone
fits and works really well on this new
paradigm this newfound importance on
each individual player to feel like they
can really make an impact on the game
we're trying to obviously maintain the
original character's identity and
overall silhouette colors statements but
also kind of bring something a little
bit new
we can make balance adjustments really
quick as fast as our design team sees
that there's an issue jeff goodman and
the rest of the hero design team have
been loving all the feedback coming in
they have tons of awesome ideas about
how to change or adjust balance so
heroes like erisa got a major rework
we're looking at how many barriers are
in place you think about overwatch you
think of these really protective shields
we're looking at it from the perspective
of you know what if she didn't have that
what would that even look like we're
just always looking for great
opportunities to change for the better
i'm really excited about how we've
refreshed all the maps i think we've
done a lot of great changes especially
for pvp a lot of our old stuff just
looks gorgeous now we've done a lot with
the art and with lighting and shadows
and just made stuff pop a little bit
more we also added some options with
like daytime nighttime i think all of
the overwatch team maps are custom
recorded in the actual place we've hired
a field recordist to actually go capture
ambience of the real world location we
realize it's a subtle detail but those
are the things that really make these
maps come to life
we have done a pass playing all the old
maps and 5v5 and adjusting things for
that kind of setup whether it's moving
cover around just a little bit or
tweaking a door in the beta we're
listening to feedback so we're going to
improve each map based on what the
players have been seeing we've been
working on these for a little while now
and we're really excited about it we're
really happy with the positive feedback
once people were able to play it and i
think it was an important milestone for
us to get it in players hands
competitive play is a different thing to
a lot of different people and we really
didn't think we were providing enough
tools and measures to actually help
players out if they did want to improve
we're reworking our scoreboard to
provide more information to players as
they're like playing through the match
but once they finish the match
we're actually going to provide
after-action report so you can look at
the report while you're in queue you can
actually go into
your history section and look we want to
work towards providing you with
information that will help you
improve your game
we've been getting feedback from a lot
of different areas from our you know
community team like streamers
influencers we've also been getting a
lot of feedback from overwatch league
players we do want to actually provide a
bit of like feeling of progression so
one of the other changes we're making
alongside that is not making your skill
rating quite so grand here right now
it's a very hard number instead of
numeric skill rating we're adding these
skill tiers within the larger ones if
you see someone at a really high skill
tier you know that that person is not
just that good of an overwatch player
but they've earned it
one of the cool things about overwatch 2
is it has this new push game mode and
maps along with it push is a pvp game
mode
on several different new maps we've been
playing it in the beta and we've
actually been using it in overwatch
league as well and once we started play
testing it it was kind of an instant hit
there's
a level it has one path that goes all
the way through it from one base to the
other and the middle is ts1
and he's this lovable robot with a pair
of barricades next to him and the
players essentially fighting for control
and if they take control by taking out
the other enemy team ts1 will move a
barricade towards the enemy base to win
you either get that barricade all the
way to the enemy base or
after a certain amount of time did you
move your barricade farther than the
enemy team did it's very fair game mode
i think the maps are great it provides
for a lot of different like locations
where a lot of great fights can happen
we develop a lot of engine upgrades in
the game so this allows us to do faster
iteration this was a huge effort by our
engine team to allow the art team to
build faster more detailed environments
in a shorter amount of time you will get
to experience the game world we wanted
to feel much more immersive
overwatch 2 is a dream for audio
features it's everything we've ever
really wanted to do we really go into
every little bit of detail trying to
find a way that every sound will cut
through when we started on overwatch one
we were really really focused on the
headphone mix we we thought for you know
a pc first kind of game
we realized that people listened to
overwatch in all types of different
places so now we support home theater
dolby atmos in the game
now consoles offer all kinds of new
things too like 3d audio that we're
supporting there's new voice lines new
conversations between all of the
favorite heroes and we have so many
there'll be more that'll just come to
the game over time we've written 25 000
voice lines for overwatch dude
so tons of new features and the reality
is that overwatch scales even beyond
that all the way up to giant sports
arenas for our overwatch finals
everything you like about overwatch
you're gonna get that in overwatch too
but even more you know we're really
listening to feedback a lot of it we
felt like man we really think this is
gonna be super fun we just need people
to be able to play it
october 4th is really just the beginning
i mean just amazing work by the entire
team and i personally can't wait to
finally get my hands on the full pvp
experience when overwatch 2 goes live
this october and october is just the
start as paul mentioned earlier
overwatch 2 will continue to evolve and
grow over time but what does that mean
for us the players well i went behind
the scenes to talk with the team working
on new seasonal content and find out
more so let's take a closer look at what
players can expect when overwatch 2
expands post launch
we're really excited because people will
just be able to just fully immerse
yourself in the maps and the storylines
and the heroes
with the new seasonal model we'll be
able to drop a ton of content in very
frequently as we're updating the game
through these big seasonal drops
we're looking at releasing heroes every
other season and then a map in between
those and on top of that we're looking
at dropping a ton of content involving
skins and other great goodies for
players to get their hands on for each
seasonal drop
we have so much that we want to do in
overwatch to develop this game because
we think it's the next step for us we
think there is so much more we could
bring i'm really happy moving to our new
seasonal base schedule making this
really huge commitment to regular
updates it's exciting at the same time
because i know what this team can do we
really want players to be able to
anticipate when things are going to
enter the game with all the new content
and events coming in it's even more
important to just make sure that
everybody knows what's coming and along
with the free to play change we're doing
away with loot boxes entirely we have a
new battle pass model coming in and with
store as well so players will have a lot
more control about how they interact
with the game and how they acquire new
content
we've been working on so many things
over the past couple years i'm most
excited for folks to see some of the new
heroes that we've been kind of cooking
up it's a bunch of different reasons why
we choose to make a hero we're trying to
follow the narrative pick the hero that
makes sense or do we need to create a
hero that answers this matter counters a
certain strategy that's too strong in
the game we've got two more supports and
another tank in just the first couple of
seasons and we're still working on new
characters for a year year and a half
down the line as well there's characters
that folks have already seen glimpses of
in the story and there's also characters
that you've never seen before never
heard about
we were looking at making sure that new
heroes fit within this new very
fast-paced paradigm and less shields and
crowd control you can see a lot of that
reflected in team play moments but with
a much faster pace vibe
we want to push the sci-fi the
futuristic feeling of maps there's a
touch of sci-fi everywhere you look so
this is something that was a bit more
subtle in overwatch one we really want
players to feel that the world takes
place in not so distant future coming up
next is rio rio a new pvp map pretty
sure everybody's gonna love that one as
well it's a great map it's close to the
team many people on the team are from
brazil so it was kind of fun to inject
the culture the colors the vibe into
this map
there's a map that takes place in
portugal this map is pretty close to the
team because our lead environment artist
he's from portugal
people from the location should really
get a sense that we've done a ton of
research
and we were very inspired and i think we
captured it pretty beautifully in the
game it is a push map one of the newest
game modes and we tried some pretty
interesting layouts for this one so we
hope the players like it we definitely
want the game to feel like a globe
trotting adventure
there's new types of content from what
you're used to in overwatch one we have
charms we have banners
the current make the skin that's in the
works that i worked on actually is genji
he's got this kind of cyberpunk japanese
demonic theme mythic skins are meant to
be this
next tier of skins above legendary we
want players to be able to go in there
and pick and choose certain pieces meant
to be this extra awesome legendary skin
that you can customize we're
concurrently developing quite a few
mythic skins that are going to be
released over the seasons all this
amazing stuff all of the amazing skins
for weapon charms really what we're
looking for there is just for the
players to be able to express themselves
and dress their character up one of our
core tenants on overwatch visually is to
focus a lot on the first person view we
want you to be able to see it and enjoy
it while you're playing the game one
thing that was really important to us
was to make sure that players if they
earn anything in the game anywhere that
they're able to use it everywhere so if
you earn something on console or a pc or
an overwatch one you can always use it
in anywhere in overwatch too as well and
with each new season there will be a ton
of new content and a new battle pass as
well
these seasonal updates will allow us to
be constantly infusing the game with new
content new heroes new maps so the game
is going to feel fresh just all the time
there's always going to be something for
you to do or to work towards there's
never going to be a point where you're
like gosh i don't have anything to do
being able to provide players with new
heroes every so often new maps it is
going to be a growing and evolving game
there's so much for us to explore as we
move forward
get ready it's going to be really
exciting really fun
with both pvp and pve there's going to
be really great content for you to
immerse yourself in and continue to play
over and over again with your friends
we can't wait for october 4th we're just
excited to be back
[Music]
i mean it's so great to see how much
thought and care your team is pouring
into uh really elevating the game
through post-launch season so you
mentioned that pve is coming in 2023.
now can you tell us how the development
is going and why the team is committed
to bringing these type of experiences
into overwatch we're all so invested in
the world of overwatch and and the
heroes that live in it and through the
years we've developed cinematics
animated shorts and graphic novels for
our players who just want to get deeper
into the lore
with pve we have an opportunity to go a
step further to go deeper into diverse
storytelling in ways that we really just
haven't been able to before so we are
planning to expand the overwatch
universe through these seasons that we
just described and we will start
delivering this pve gameplay in 2023 pve
will be delivered through the live
service and that means we'll be able to
deliver and tell more overwatch stories
and create more opportunities to
experience our heroes here's a sneak
peek at what we're working on
the team's goal for pve and overwatch 2
is to basically move the overall story
of overwatch for we've told a lot of
short stories along the way there are a
lot of 2b continues it's time for us to
answer those questions
close off some of those stories ask new
questions so the new game will
definitely move the overall canon of the
lore of overwatch ford get those doors
open for the pvp live service for
certain seasons you're also going to get
some pve maps you'll be fighting null
sector and at least some of the maps
they've come back and they're mad so
it's overwatch's job to take them out
there's going to be content for you to
immerse yourself in and continue to play
over and over again a lot of the older
guys from the original overwatch team
they're coming back but they need help
with some of the younger generation like
brigitte and lucio so
we're going to tell the story of how
overwatch basically gets back together
another thing we want to do with the
story is to showcase more of where the
characters are from for example torbjorn
is from gothenburg players will get a
chance to see what torbjorn's factory
looks like you can play pve with your
friends and immerse yourself in the
world and stay inside of it a little bit
longer
wow this is incredible it's so great to
get that first sneak peek so thank you
so much for sharing that before i let
you run off is there anything you would
like to say to the community watching
yeah we are
so excited for today and we're so
excited for you all to be able to see
everything that we want to show you and
we really cannot wait for
october 4th when we're all playing this
game together neither can i now we'll
also take a deeper look at a brand new
hero that's right jungkook queen who
will be playable for the first time
during the beta later this month already
now before we do that though we thought
we'd take a look at jungle queen's
origin story to get to know the next
great overwatch character a little
better paul aaron we appreciate you
spending some time with us today best of
luck to you and of course your entire
team as you gear up for that launch
let's take a look
[Music]
foreign
what the world's been seventeen
[Music]
machete
there will
[Applause]
wow just wow what an unbelievable new
hero and we will dive deeper into jungle
queen but first i wanted to introduce
art director dion rogers and a few new
faces to the show we have narrative
designer miranda moyer and cinematic
director ben dye thank you guys so much
for joining welcome yeah thank you for
having us
i'm really excited to share this it
takes an army to create a game i mean
the effort is clearly paying off that
short was just so much fun to watch now
it's been such an exciting week for
everyone watching but i'm sure for you
three as well uh players have learned
that the next beta is coming on june
28th can you tell me a little bit more
about what we can expect to see in this
beta the biggest thing is open the
console players this time we're gonna
add a new map rio junker queen will be
playable finally so this should be
pretty fun i mean i personally can't
wait to get my hands on jungle queen and
you're representing her right there with
the cool shirt as well
what a great segue so let's talk more
about the newest overwatch hero i think
it's super exciting i know everybody has
been really anticipating this character
for a long time she's been super
prominent in our lore ever since the
junkertown map came out and i think
people have really been looking forward
to finally getting to experience
everything that she has to offer what
makes jungkook queen so unique and why
do you think the oh players will love
her
so junker queen is interesting usually
when we start a character we do a bunch
of drawings and and we have a little
story but she was kind of born out of
the junkertown map we started to create
this map that was associated with
roadhog and junkrat this narrative
started to appear where they've been
kicked out of the city and so we're like
who kicked them out and we're like well
maybe there's some sort of leader so we
had the kind of junkertown decree that
you can see in the level
and then over time it kind of developed
that it was a queen during the short
we're actually developing her
personality she's full of attitude you
know that's what we love about her is
she she's really really strong so she's
very recognizable and obviously the lore
behind her
is very interesting so some of that
potentially can bounce off what the the
game design will be it's great to hear
that it's just such a collaboration with
the overwatch team yeah this this is a
fun part about working together uh the
overwatch universe it's filled with
memorable heroes and as you say yourself
ben it does take a village of dedicated
developers to really bring each one of
those to life but in a meaningful way so
let's take a deeper look at the making
of jungle queen
when we started on chucker queen first
we have to decide what kind of role
she's going to take so she's a tank
she's a really aggressive tank you know
we didn't want her to be kind of a
reinhardt style stay back and guard her
team she's got this very ferocious
nature and we wanted for that to be
represented in her game play as well
personally what i'm most excited about
junker queen is just her big axe you
know just to be able to swing that thing
around is awesome it's always great to
have some sort of anchor point to make
sure we really incorporate this axe into
her abilities
her secondary we call jagged blade if
you do your quick melee attack she will
kind of swing with the blade instead of
a normal punch um it does a little bit
of extra damage and creates a wound on
the enemy so she can throw the blade as
her secondary fire and it's really a
great sort of skill shot to be able to
land on the enemies but shake a moving
enemy if you can land it and after you
throw it she'll recall it and it the
force of recalling it uh if it's stuck
into somebody will actually pull them
forward so she can actually kind of pull
people to herself if you can manage to
stick that blade into somebody for
trekker queen's ultimate we have an
ability called rampage she creates this
kind of whirlwind of magnetized metal
including her weapons and like whirls
around her and then she dashes forward
and you try to go through as many
enemies as possible and tag them all up
that also wounds everybody which is
really important because it's very easy
to hit with large effects so it heals
you for a lot but also it creates a
debuff on the enemies that reduces the
healing that they receive to zero
our sound designer has done an
incredible job with her she's full of
snarky fun to the way she plays so all
throughout her kit there's little guitar
sounds actually hidden so if you listen
to her acts she pulls it out and there's
a big screech on the guitar strings she
pulls it forward we have a wonderful
actor named leah who we found after a
huge global search trying to find the
right voice for her here i am it's
really amazing when the right actor
matches the character and the
personality you feel the sort of magic
that comes out of it i think players are
gonna love her she's scary she's awesome
she's a departure from any other hero
that we have here you know this is just
a straightforward badass character she's
just been so much fun to work on and i'm
just so glad to get her in people's
hands finally
the queen of juncker town has arrived so
how does the jungle queen fit into the
overall world of overwatch i think
drunker queen's pretty interesting
because there have been previous rulers
of junkertown uh junker queen was not
always the queen and the old rulers of
junkertown have always been kind of
content to just you know lord over the
city but junk queen she has very big
acts and big ideas to go along with it
what did you aim to achieve when
developing jungle queen we want to tell
deeper stories for our heroes have
heroes that are connected to the world
of the game big thing for overwatch 2 is
to move the lore of overwatch along so
these type of heroes help that what are
her abilities and how do those abilities
actually make her successful in the role
she's in what's pretty awesome about
this hero she was developed when 5v5
from the start she was never a part of
the 6v6 world of overwatch knowing she's
the only tank on the team
what abilities that will help bolster
the team she has this commanding shout
it boosts the speed and armor of the
heroes around her so
especially you need to push through a
choke she does the shout all the players
hear it they move forward she has a
bunch of weapons you know she i think
she named one of her weapons right yeah
her knife that she throws and pulls back
is named gracie
a lot of her abilities kind of drain on
the heroes and gives her health back her
ultimate basically it shoots you forward
and you do this whirlwind with her axe
that it does a bit like a big antenate
on everybody around you she's very
aggressive and then people are going to
have a ton of fun playing it are there
any particular maps uh you feel that
jungle queen plays really well on
getting close is where she's pretty
dangerous so maps that have a
nice flank routes allow her to get in
closer to the enemy and then start to do
her what she does best is reckoning so
another big piece of news over the
weekend that got the overwatch community
just
buzzing
with excitement was of course the tease
of your new cinematic trailer the
wastelander which we're going to
premiere here in just a few moments but
before we do uh ben can you tell us a
little bit more about it i remember in
the in the very beginning of our story
room jam sessions there's talk about
what type of story you want to tell
right uh should we include junk crash we
include road hog but ultimately i think
we wanted to center
our focus on exactly on our main
character it's a character reveal it's
potentially a sort of a revenge origin
story you know actually give a little
bit more lore into junkertown how she
become the queen how was that society um
being
governed you know prior to to she become
the queen well you and the team you guys
pour so much love and time into these
cinematics and introduce heroes
it really shines through i want to thank
all three of you for taking the time to
sit down with me today and sharing all
of this amazing information
i know the fans at home are on the edges
of their seats so am i waiting to see it
so let's take a look at the world
premiere of the och 2's new cinematic
the wastelander featuring the latest
hero jungle
queen take them out with the rest of the
garbage
let the wasteland deal with them
[Music]
please
[Music]
what
i'm not allowed to have a bad dream
[Applause]
no wastelander
has ever made it to the reckoning before
but here i am
a free-for-all
with zero rules
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
not in 13 years of rule
not until
today
[Music]
[Applause]
did you really think this would be a
fair fight
don't survive the reckoning
unless the winner grabs your mercy
[Music]
that's why i've got to win this whole
all right
let's get this started
[Music]
scavengers like you ain't so bad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on big boy
not you'd be any better
[Applause]
[Music]
at least i wouldn't shoot my friends in
the back
[Music]
voicelander scum
[Music]
[Music]
everyone here
not in this arena
oh
this makeup has a bigger magnet
[Music]
[Applause]
that could have gone better
[Music]
[Music]
you idiot i'll kill you for that
no
not today
[Music]
oh
mercy
i'll give you
the same mercy you showed my family 13
years ago
get out of my city
[Music]
[Applause]
that turned out all right but now
they're probably wondering what sort of
changes i'll make around here
well buckler
they're about to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the worst
so
[Music]
well that about wraps things up for
today here at blizzard i want to thank
each and every one of you for tuning in
and make sure to follow play overwatch
on social for all the latest news and
announcements about overwatch 2 and i
can't wait to see you all in game
[Music]
which one's your favorite
[Music]
mine's tracer
she's like she's not the cavalry's here
you're one of those heroes aren't you
before me i see the future
human
machine
you know there's more out there
don't you
even the best journeys end
but a new one is right around the corner
[Music]
i am your queen
let's take him to the wasteland
one punch is all i need
nice work team
keep it moving
i cannot wait to push
you be kind
boom baby
check me out
[Music]
get in there
it takes a team to tango
[Music]
[Music]
you